what else is there other up document is
that you like that we can recommend cuz
I love documents yes
generation wealth have you seen that I
just watched that is the same remember
that I saw it it's of the lady that did
those photography yes right and yes
those books yes and I saw it and that
was really crazy it was fair yes very
upsetting but it's very sad very sad yes
an interesting comment on materialism
and I think that that there's that
German financier who's hiding from the
the IRS in Germany and he's very is a
complete supervillain and he's smoking a
cigar yes
yeah but he says a line which I think
that's really true he said if you think
that money will solve all of your
problems then you have never had any new
I felt bad for not his son but his son's
girlfriend yeah she's just like in this
family weird I was in the fire document
so funny that we both notice Acker
although yeah yeah
well she was because she was the most
human person than the interpreter was
yeah she was looking at everything like
yeah she was clearly in pain yes she was
in pain and she's like almost on the
fence of why am I in this relationship
yeah right because you know does that
get passed on through that douchebag
kind of mentality yeah yeah have you
seen three identical strangers here no
that's the next I've heard that's very
weird
no watch it's like it's it's a debate
about scientific breakthrough versus
nature versus nurture no ethics are you
how do you how do you gather that type
of information versus you know the
ethics of it all you would really like a
cross you it's amazing yeah yeah yeah I
know a little bit about the thing and
I'm looking forward to reading it that
it's a seen it you know what I the
documentaries I love though I love
watching documentaries about bands I
hate have you seen the one of Pulp like
but but I
the documentary I hated the band Rush
yeah I saw that what do yeah I like Neil
Peart the drama riot right and how he's
very standoffish at shows like I saw
that documentary where people come and
he's so he's so good he's like kind of
like the Rachmaninoff a [ __ ] drumming
yeah he's he's just likes his solitude
he doesn't like to do the photo shoots
and all that kind of stuff yeah but I
hated rush to and then I saw that I mean
anvil the story of anvil yeah that's
another great one right happy and then
the one about journey I I mean I can't
tell you the depth of my losing for the
band Journey yeah and then I and then I
watched the documentary and I still
don't don't like the music was that the
little Filipino because he's our
national treasure in the Philippines no
no no I think it's an amazing story is
amazing but you know he's a dime-a-dozen
back home I mean I'd say yeah he is he's
just he's incredible but I just think
Filipinos produce incredible singing
talent know it's like Sean Connery
impersonations and Scott yeah God Shake
in the eyes
geology like you could just go on
YouTube and say Filipino kids singing in
the mall and he just picks up like a
karaoke machine
yeah and he's belting out these ballads
and he's like sixty years old and it's
just what you know what I didn't like
about that is that remember the first
show we did in Brazil who aren't Alpina
Yeah right and then they were like he's
dancing moving around too much he hasn't
grasped the essential dignity of singing
for journey stand still and just sing
the great don't stop don't stop believin
yeah how many journey frontman have
there been there Steve Perry and there's
that other Steve and I don't know we
don't know I just it's Steve Perry in
the Filipino guy yeah no I think that's
I think that was like when they hired
George Lazenby be James Bond from one
movie see you guys didn't even know that
right yeah failure was it after Sean
Connery yeah Sean Connery and then
before Roger Brewer there was a guy
called George Lazenby that one he was a
male model yeah they thought they were
gonna teach Sean Connery a lesson by
saying we can just get any pretty boy
and make it fun he's like right go ahead
[ __ ] yeah this guy and it was
it's worth seeing it so bad oh really is
like yeah yeah I want to watch I think
it's called on Her Majesty's Secret
Service how do you even know that but
okay you know yeah yeah I grew up in
Scotland well let's give Craig a round
of applause guys he was [ __ ] amazing
[Music]